who are you I'm your daughter Nora from
the future and I think I made a big big
mistake
Barry something you've been meaning to
tell us what no this kid is not my
grandson from the future or any when
heck iris and I don't even have kids um
Barry what I am pregnant what I found
out this morning I was gonna tell you
tonight
in private hi dad
hi ed dawn wait there - in there we're
having twins boilers
HQ this is transport x17 you are hereby
under arrest for violating the
anti-meta-human accent I'm metahuman ya
matter humans have been illegal since
2021 didn't you guys hear the memo hey
everybody its charlie I've been getting
a lot of requests to do a video for noir
Alan and tornado twins for season 5 so
we met Nora Allen but a lot of people
are wondering now because like they did
on Young Justice Barry and iris have
twins in the comics that are called the
tornado twins they're named dawn and
Dawn which and it sounds a little bit
confusing if you're not a big comic book
reader but even though we have a
flashpoint 2.0 situation with Nora I
think that the show is doing something
different so I'll explain what's going
on but if you're finding me for the
first time there's a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so the big thing at
the beginning of the season is as Barry
said we're going to need more diapers so
people are like okay clearly they're
foreshadowing that he and iris are gonna
have children in the future nor showing
up as them paying that off but when he
says more diapers people were expecting
twins like he was already going to need
diapers so one I think the reason why we
didn't hear him speak that line during
the finale is that it was one of the
scenes that hit the cutting room floor
so if you didn't know there were a
couple scenes that they cut out of the
finale one of them was a teaser for the
season 5 villain I've already done a
video for that so I'll link it at the
end of this but when Nora walks in and
says this house is bitchin it was them I
think you know paying off all the
gibberish from the beginning of the
season and they felt like they didn't
need to include all the other gibberish
lines so I think that in this moment
here after Nora said I'm your daughter
nor Alan from the future he probably had
that we're gonna need more diapers line
of dialogue and maybe they just felt
like it didn't work with the tone of
what the scene was supposed to be but
you look at his face and it looks like
he's supposed to be crapping his pants
so they probably just felt like it
didn't work in the moment like oh well
whatever people will understand she's
supposed to be nor Alan that's what the
diapers were about at the beginning of
the season but a lot of people were
looking at diggle's baby after
flashpoint in wondering if one of Nora's
mistakes caused her twin to be a race if
you don't remember Diggle had a baby
girl before flashpoint called Sarah
named after Sarah Lance from legends of
tomorrow at
flashpoint berry changed the past when
he came back that baby girl was a boy
named John Dingell jr. me lava
Hey
apparently you had a daughter
[Music]
I had a daughter Mary
maybe John was baby Sarah
[Music]
that's what you get this rate you just
uh you just erased a daughter from my
life people were wondering if maybe Nora
did something like that to the reason
why I think this is the same version of
Nora like there's only one child I don't
think there are twins right now that
doesn't mean that won't change in the
future people are also wondering if she
might have an identical twin I don't
think that's what's going on I think
that would be kind of a cheap twist they
said that they had the idea for Nora
before season 4 ever started they said
they pitched it to the network and they
decided to call her Nora around this
time last year when they were coming up
with the idea for season 4 this is the
reason for calling her Nora was to honor
Barry's mother because Barry's been
really close with his mother on the TV
show but also because they knew that
people would figure out who she is and
they wanted to do their own version
which I think is the biggest nail in the
coffin to the twin theory that they're
just gonna do Nora that doesn't mean
they won't have more children in the
future I just think that Nora is meant
to be it in whatever the mistake that
they're trying to fix is it has nothing
to do with bringing back a secret
sibling because this also gets into
legends of tomorrow continuity if you
guys remember sorry she's from the year
2042 Nora is from the year 2048 remember
what was happening during that time
period metahumans had been outlawed in
Argus had been locking them all up so I
talked a little bit about the season 5
villain and about how he was hunting
down metahumans it sounds like they're
using the cicada villain to bring this
post-apocalyptic future to bear because
he has the ability to take metahumans
powers so they are kind of doing tornado
twins comic book stuff without actually
doing the twin part there's also a
number of practical reasons why they
wouldn't want to do twins one like they
had to get rid of Wally West this season
on the flash because they didn't have
enough money to do special effects they
just had a really big problem handling
two speedsters and a Ralph at the same
time so it's just easier from a story
standpoint to deal with one new
speedster and one child that you meet
across all these little past instances
so they said Nora is the one that
visited them in the past these four
times it's not some secret twin but they
are pulling from the comics for her
origin story because the tornado twins
in the comics dawn and Dawn come from
the
30th century where metahumans have been
outlawed so a lot of people were
wondering why she gave iris that weird
look like she wasn't really happy to see
her and she was trying to avoid her in
the past well in the future
the tornado twins say that their mother
the older version of iris from the
comics told them that they weren't
allowed to use their powers for fear
that they would be arrested by the
people that were taking in metahumans
have been illegal since 2021 so if
that's kind of the same case in this
future timeline of the TV show then that
would explain why she doesn't like iris
as much right here like she told her not
to use her abilities so whatever Nora's
mistake is it sounds like it has
something to do with the different
members of team flash and she came back
into the past to visit them to get more
information to be able to change things
in the future for the better so just all
those things coupled with the fact that
she's wearing excesses costume from the
comics I think points to them not doing
actual tornado twins she's just a single
child and they didn't want to go from
zero babies to a billion because they
already had cecile babies happening over
here
so hopefully that explains how they're
doing comic book tornado twins without
doing the twins part like they're just
doing a simplified version of that but
leave all your video requests in the
comments below there's supposed to be an
Aquaman trailer dropping sometime soon
if it does I will totally do a video for
it but click here to learn all about the
season 5 villain and click here for all
my flash season 5 videos thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight